[Music]
would you spend a night
at the top of the first tower to space
at 100 kilometers above sea level it
would be the highest
structure that humans have ever built
this tower could house almost a million
residents but
would that be worth the giant price tag
of
25 trillion dollars
could humans even survive the extreme
conditions at the top
would the earth's crust be able to
support the weight
of this massive structure
and how could we prevent it from falling
over
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we built a tower to outer space
when it comes to building a space tower
there are a lot of obstacles to plan
around
first there are the extremely cold
temperatures that could
freeze you to death then there are the
category 5 hurricane winds that could
cause the tower to sway and fall over
oh and did we mention there would be
barely any air pressure at the top
so you'd likely get altitude sickness
which
could kill you but even with all those
hazards
we still think we can build one safe
enough for humans to stay in
want to see what it looks like
[Music]
yes it might look a little strange but
this is how we'd have to structure our
tower if we don't want it to fall over
if we didn't shape our tower like a
pyramid it would buckle under its own
weight
tilt to the side and crash to the ground
at 100 kilometers tall this pyramid
would need a base
as large as the area of hong kong to
keep it stable
it would also need a reinforced core to
prevent it from swaying
in the extreme winds found at the top of
our atmosphere
at 70 kilometers above sea level winds
of 252 kilometers per hour can occur
and the top of our tower would be 30
kilometers higher than that
now that we've got a stable structure
figured out
we need to find a way to transport
people up to the top
traditionally elevators are limited to a
height
of about 500 meters after that they
would be
too heavy so we're going to need
something
a little more modern like magnet powered
elevators for instance
but even with those we'd still be
looking at
super long elevator rides to go up and
down
this would be a serious problem if we
wanted our tower to contain
residences and offices one group that
would be happy about these
extra long elevator rides would be the
advertising industry
talk about a captive audience
instead of just watching commercial
after commercial
wouldn't you rather use all this free
time to get creative
and even earn extra money well you can
do that
with vocal vocal is a publishing
platform for creators of
all kinds like bloggers podcasters
youtubers and more
to connect with engaged audiences and
earn money
you can promote your latest content by
embedding it in a story on vocal like
your most recent youtube video podcast
episode
spotify song or more there are over 30
topic-based communities where you can
explore your interests
as a creator on vocal you'll earn money
every time your story is read and you
can earn tips sent from readers
vocal also hosts weekly challenges for
your chance to win
cash prizes and more here at what if
we've been sharing our own stories on
vocal
check out the link in our description
box to read our most recent story
where we wrote about what would happen
if everyone stopped drinking coffee
spoiler alert it wouldn't be good for
those long elevator rides
so sign up as a creator on vocal today
to start earning from your stories
and get connected with a new audience
you've got all this free time these days
why not put it to good use
but before we go selling our elevator ad
space
we need to see if it would be safe for
us to go up that high in the first place
at the top of mount everest the air
pressure
is dangerously low about one-third of
the pressure on the ground
and our space tower would be 11 times
taller than that
if we didn't regulate the air pressure
inside the skyscraper
you could experience altitude sickness
and if we didn't regulate the
temperature in there
you could freeze to death by the time
you reach the top
[Music]
next we'd have to figure out how to
provide running water throughout the
tower
it would take a lot of pressure to pump
water up so high
we would need hundreds of water
reservoirs located on different levels
throughout the building
these water reservoirs would be filled
in sequence with
each one being used to fill the one
above all the way to the top
if the residents were to use as much
water as
the residents of the burj khalifa do per
day
we estimate that our space tower would
use about
13 olympic sized swimming pools of water
per day
and that's a lot to pump up
and even if we solved all those
challenges
there would still be one underlying
issue that
could inevitably sink the whole project
i'm talking about the earth's crust
the earth's crust is only about 30
kilometers thick
with a soft mantle underneath it
like a house on unstable soil the tower
would start to sink down into the ground
over the years
as the earth's crust would be unable to
sustain its weight
so for now maybe we'll just have to
settle for
the tall towers we already have
or if you really want that nice view
from space
you could always sign up to be one of
the first space tourists
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]